merci
[Musique]
à mes 18 ans j'ai pris ma première carte
à l'UMP je me suis engagé comme militant
j'ai gravi tous les échelons je me suis
devenu grâce à la confiance de Christian
Jacob secrétaire général des
républicains et je sais à quel point
notre famille politique militante a
besoin demain à sa tête d'un homme qui a
été maire engagé et qui a su porter des
combats difficiles il nous faut un
combattant nous n'avons plus le droit au
chamailleries aux divisions aux
règlements de comptes il est peut-être
temps de faire en sorte que notre
famille politique prenne le plus beau
risque ce risque c'est l'audace il est
temps de tourner les pages faire en
sorte que demain nous soyez fiers d'être
représenté par celles et ceux qui
rassemblaient parleront à tous les
Français la seule droite qui va c'est la
Droite populaire
[Applaudissements]
mes chers amis bonjour à toutes et à
tous et merci les premiers mots seront
des mots de remerciement merci à toutes
et à tous d'être là merci d'avoir tenu
bon merci d'avoir été fidèle durant tant
d'années merci de n'avoir rien cédé rien
lâcher au faciliter à tout ce qui aurait
pu vous décourager depuis des années les
premiers mots mes premiers mots sont des
mots de remerciement parce que nous nous
serions pas là les uns et les autres mes
amis concurrents et aujourd'hui candidat
avec moi si vous n'étiez pas là alors
merci du fond du coeur de faire que la
droite est encore vivante partout dans
les territoires et qu'aujourd'hui nous
ayons ce beau rendez-vous démocratique
merci à tous de faire en sorte que nos
valeurs que nos idées ne disparaissent
pas l'âme du futur président des
républicains doit être l'âme de
militants oui un militant la plus belle
des fonctions c'est celle du militant ce
n'est pas celle du président des
républicains ce n'est pas celle du futur
chapeau à plume qui va rajouter une
plume sur son chapeau non la plus belle
des missions c'est celle qui demain nous
poussera à la présidence des
républicains à militer avec vous mes
chers amis de quoi avons-nous besoin
avons-nous besoin de grands mots
avons-nous besoin de grandes phrases
avons-nous besoin de grands concepts
n'avons-nous pas besoin plutôt de
rebâtir la maison de rebâtir ce grand
mouvement militant qui a toujours fait
notre réussite électorale nous avons
besoin de revenir sur le terrain de vous
reparler nous avons besoin que le futur
président des républicains demain ne
soit pas déconnecté de vos réalités
qu'il ne ne couvre pas ce que sont nos
fédérations ce qu'est notre vie
militante nous avons besoin de
reconstruire cette maison depuis
plusieurs semaines je sillonne comme mes
collègues les routes de France je viens
dans nos départements je viens vous voir
et je vois que partout il y a ce qui
nous permet encore de tenir bon des
femmes et des hommes engagés qui ne
demandent rien d'autre que nos valeurs
puissent continuer demain à vivre encore
il y a quelques années lorsque je venais
tout juste d'avoir 18 ans j'ai pris ma
première carte politique cette toute
première carte politique je l'ai prise à
l'UMP je viens d'une famille qui n'a
jamais fait de politique mais parents
n'étaient pas engagés mon jeune frère ne
fait pas de politique mais je savais à
cette époque là et j'avais cette
conviction intime qui ne m'a pas quitté
depuis que seule la politique permettait
de changer la vie de nos concitoyens à
mes 18 ans j'ai adhéré dans le Lot dans
une terre qui était réputée absolument
imprenable pour nos convictions et nos
valeurs politiques à 18 ans je me suis
dit que seule la politique permettait de
lutter contre toutes les fatalités que
si je voulais demain que la France que
mon pays change comme je le souhaitais
alors il fallait m'engager
je sais que vous avez pris le même
chemin qu'il y a quelques années vous
avez commencé par le militantisme et
qu'aujourd'hui conseiller nationaux de
notre famille politique vous êtes celles
et ceux qui représentaient l'âme de
l'engagement politique oui à 18 ans
j'étais persuadé et je le suis plus
encore aujourd'hui que seul la droite
était la famille politique qui pouvait
parler à tous les Français oui à 18 ans
j'étais convaincu que l'âme profonde de
la politique l'honneur de la politique
était de parler à tous les Français à
chaque Français sans en exclure aucun
oui j'ai rêvé j'ai rêvé de ce que
Jacques Chirac avait fait en 1995 j'ai
rêvé de cette magnifique campagne
électorale
qui ici depuis Paris comme partout en
France a fait de notre famille politique
une grande famille populaire et je ne
laisserai jamais ceux qui n'ont pas
cette nostalgie parce qu'ils ont pas
participé à cette magnifique aventure
nous dire que la campagne de 1995
n'était pas une magnifique campagne pour
les Français à cette époque là
souvenons-nous de ce qui était la droite
la droite parler autant aux éboueurs de
Paris qu'aux paysan de la Corrèze qu'au
patron du CAC 40 souvenons-nous 2016
souvenons-nous de cette campagne
électorale à l'occasion laquelle la
droite était ce qu'elle a toujours été
populaire je me souviens des meetings
qu'à l'époque nous organisions à la
sortie des usines de chez Michelin je me
souviens des chefs d'entreprise qui nous
accompagnaient je me souviens de cette
jeunesse qui ne nous avait pas quitté à
l'époque et qui nous a permis de
reconquérir le cœur des Français oui la
seule droite que je connaisse c'est
celle pour laquelle je me suis engagé à
18 ans c'est le droit de populaire oh je
ne crois pas tous ces concepts qui
consistent à nous diviser encore plus je
ne crois pas qu'il y aurait une droite
libérale contre une droite conservatrice
je ne crois pas qu'il y aurait une vraie
droite comme une fosse droite une droite
dure contre une droite molle et chers
amis lorsqu'on fait 5 % à l'élection
présidentielle on ne cherche pas à ce
saucissonner encore on ne cherche pas à
faire des sous-chapelle on sera ensemble
et on se souvient que le seul message
que nous pouvons porter demain c'est
celui qui permettra de s'adresser à tous
les Français alors oui notre famille
politique c'est celle qui croit que la
France a un avenir notre famille
politique c'est celle qui dit que nos
frontières doivent être imprenables que
oui la souveraineté c'est d'abord le
contrôle de nos frontières oui notre
famille politique c'est celle qui dit
que la droite et la France portent
l'idéal pour chaque Français oui notre
famille politique
c'est celle qui ne se résoudra jamais à
ce que les injustices s'installent dans
le pays et mis nos concitoyens oui notre
famille politique c'est celle qui veut
changer le destin c'est celle qui n'a
pas la trouille c'est celle qui n'a pas
peur constamment d'avoir des idées
nouvelles c'est celle qui est audacieuse
qui est conquérante oui notre famille
politique c'est celle qui est capable
d'aller là où nous ne sommes plus pour
parler aux françaises et aux Français
que nous avons abandonné est-ce que la
situation est grave pour notre famille
politique elle est sûrement
lors des dernières élections
présidentielles nous avons fait moins de
5% lors des dernières élections
européennes et je ne n'ai pas oublié
nous avons fait 8%. nous étions en 2017
lorsque avec certains de mes amis je
suis entré à l'Assemblée nationale une
centaine de députés nous sommes
aujourd'hui une soixantaine
figurez-vous que lors de la dernière
élection présidentielle moins de 1% des
moins de 25 ans nous ont fait confiance
moins de 4% des ouvriers ont voté pour
nous moins de 5% des artisans nous ont
accordé leur confiance moins de 10% de
celles et ceux qui sont des chefs
d'entreprise ont voulu faire confiance à
la droite républicaine même parmi nos
retraités même parmi nos retraités nous
n'avons pas eu plus de 15% d'électeurs
nos paysans nos agriculteurs celles et
ceux qui font l'âme de la France dont je
vous parlais qui nous ont toujours fait
confiance nous ont accordé leur suffrage
à moins de
6%. est-ce qu'il faut continuer
exactement comme avant est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment qu'il ne faut rien
changer que nous ne devons pas nous
remettre profondément en question et
bien je pense que ce qui demain nous
permettra de revenir vers les Français
et vers les échéances électorales de
manière victorieuse c'est de nous
remettre profondément en question
depuis quand la droite française
n'a-t-elle pas donné envie depuis quand
la droite française n'a-t-elle pas été
un peu lumineuse depuis quand mes chers
amis est-ce que nous n'avons pas porté
tout simplement un espoir la droite ce
n'est pas la punition la droite ce n'est
pas le fait de ressasser en permanence
toujours les mêmes échecs toujours les
mêmes histoires toujours les mêmes
querelles toujours les mêmes petites
batailles la droite c'est beaucoup plus
que ça la droite c'est celle qui est
capable de dire à chaque Français que
demain sa vie sera meilleure
oui je l'ai souvent dit et je le répète
je ne crois pas la droite des Colocs je
ne crois pas à la droite qui entre soi
bavard des discute qui a toujours le
sentiment d'avoir d'accord d'avoir
raison entre elles mais de ne jamais
aller chercher à convaincre les Français
la droite à laquelle je crois c'est
celle qui parlera aux caissières de 50
ans la droite à laquelle je crois c'est
celle qui reparlera à nos agriculteurs
la droite à laquelle je crois c'est
celle qui reparlera à tous nos jeunes
oui il n'y a pas de chemin possible
demain si nous ne redonnons pas un peu
envie aux Français oui il n'y a pas de
chemin possible demain si nous n'avons
pas le courage tourné certaines pages
mais soyons clairs tournez les pages ne
veut pas dire insulter notre passé
tourner les pages ne veut pas dire
cracher dans la soupe
je vous le redis j'ai été fier de la
magnifique campagne de 1995 j'ai été
fier de la campagne de 2007 et si j'ai
été un des premiers à dire qu'il fallait
tourner la page Nicolas Sarkozy je pense
qu'il faut le faire avec fermeté avec
détermination mais sans jamais insulter
notre passé il nous faut avoir
il nous faut avoir ce courage calme
serein de regarder l'avenir de ne pas
chercher à refaire toujours les éternels
batailles du passé si nous voulons
demain changer il nous faut non
seulement reparler à tous les Français
mais il nous faut aussi leur parler de
tous les sujets
oui les questions d'immigration sont
absolument fondamentales et vous avez eu
l'occasion lors des différents débats
nous avons eu des différentes
discussions de voir que les uns et les
autres étudiants absolument déterminés
pour reprendre le contrôle sur les
questions migratoires pour dire que non
notre politique migratoire ne pouvait
pas constamment se gérer au milieu de la
Méditerranée pour dire que clairement
nos frontières ne devraient plus être
les passoires qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
que oui nous devons veiller non pas à
augmenter le nombre de places dans les
centres de rétention dans notre pays
mais à expulser celles et ceux qui sont
sous le coup d'une obligation de quitter
le territoire français oui sur ces
sujets là la droite a toujours quelque
chose à dire mais qu'est ce que la
droite à dire sur tous les autres sujets
qu'est-ce que nous avons à dire sur les
questions d'éducation qu'est-ce que nous
avons à dire pour reconquérir cette
école pas le faire de manière sombre le
faire de manière heureuse redire à tous
les enfants de ce pays que d'où qu'il
vienne qui qu'il soit si demain il
travaille s'ils produisent des efforts
alors ils pourront réussir dans notre
école dans l'école de la République
désormais la reproduction sociale n'a
jamais été aussi grande elle n'a jamais
été aussi importante nous sommes le pays
la promesse républicaine et pourtant
dans ce pays la promesse républicaine si
vous venez d'un milieu défavorisé il y a
de très fortes chances que vous ne
réussissiez pas aussi bien que celui qui
vienne au milieu favorisé n'est-ce pas
là la grande promesse de la droite
républicaine n'est-ce pas là le chemin
que notre famille politique doit
retrouver de reparler à nos enseignants
de ne plus les abandonner de le dire que
demain nous ne les recruterons pas sur
leboncoin en les formant en quatre jours
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
mais que nous rétablirons une école
normale de la République il est formera
tous qui en fera des mecs qui en forêts
des maîtres celles et ceux qui guideront
nos enfants pour l'avenir oui la droite
elle doit reparler de l'école elle doit
reparler de l'écologie qu'avons-nous à
dire sur l'écologie voulez-vous vraiment
que nous laissions à Sandrine Rousseau
et à tous les écolos Dingo le soin seul
de parler d'écologie vous voulez
vraiment qu'il soit seul à parler à
cette majorité de Français qui se
préoccupe légitimement de notre avenir
environnemental alors oui la droite doit
demain reparler d'environnement d'abord
parce que c'est notre histoire nous ne
lavons toujours fait et parce que nous
avons des choses à dire le futur
président des républicains il devrait
être celui qui demain reparlera
notamment de la question de l'eau oui
l'eau L'eau est une question absolument
essentielle
nous sommes un pays dans lequel nous
gaspillons entre 20 et 40% de l'eau
potable avant même qu'elle arrive au
robinet les Allemands ont lancé un plan
d'investissement d'un milliard d'euros
pour rénover le réseau d'adduction d'eau
potable nous sommes un pays dans lequel
nous réutilisons moins d'hommes pour
cent des eaux usées pour irriguer notre
agriculture reparlons de l'eau parce que
c'est un sujet autrement plus important
que l'interdiction des barbecues des
piscines individuelles ou des sapins de
Noël sur nos places de village
non prend-on pas
n'empruntons pas en matière
environnementale le même chemin que la
gauche oui la gauche voudrait nous dire
que la seule voie en matière d'énergie
renouvelable c'est l'éolien et bien moi
je ne le crois pas j'assume totalement
de dire que je ne suis pas de gauche et
que parce que je ne suis pas de gauche
je considère que l'éolienne n'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga des énergies
renouvelables
nous parlions à l'instant de l'eau
[Applaudissements]
si demain nous réinvestissons dans une
autre énergie renouvelable dont personne
ne parle nos barrages hydroélectriques
ce hérité du général de Gaulle et de
Georges Pompidou si nous réinvestissons
dans nos barrages hydroélectriques la
plus belle des énergies renouvelables
alors oui nous ferons de l'écologie de
droite pas de l'écologie en mimétisme de
ce que la gauche veut nous imposer mes
chers amis surtout ces sujets nous avons
quelque chose de nouveau à dire
qu'avons-nous à dire sur des questions
aussi essentielles que toutes les
blessures du quotidien vous le savez
parmi les combats que j'ai toujours
menés il y a l'attention portée au plus
fragile Michel Barnier était un des
premiers à parler de dignité dans les
combats politiques qui ont été les siens
il est vrai que lorsqu'il y a quelques
années avec mes amis nous reparlions de
handicap nous étions parfois un peu
regardé comme des marginaux politiques à
droite je suis heureux de voir que tout
cela a progressé pour une raison simple
c'est que si la droite vaut demain
reparler à tous les Français elle ne
doit pas faire de la littérature elle
doit leur parler de ce qui les concerne
au quotidien oui lorsque nous nous
battons à l'Assemblée nationale pour
faire en sorte de déconjuguer la
location adulte handicapé nous changeons
concrètement la vie de nos concitoyens
il y a quelques jours j'étais à
Aulnay-sous-Bois pour une réunion
militante comme nous en avons beaucoup à
la fin de la réunion une dame se lève au
fond de la salle et venez monsieur le
député je n'ai jamais adhéré à aucun
parti politique mais lorsque j'ai su que
vous étiez candidat j'ai pris ma carte
pour pouvoir voter pour vous je les
remercier mais je lui ai surtout demandé
pourquoi
et cette dame m'a redit une chose
importante essentielle elle m'a dit
monsieur vous et vos amis vous m'avez
redonné à ma fille et moi de la dignité
qu'avions-nous fait pour redonner de la
dignité à cette femme et à sa fille nous
nous étions battus pour que l'allocation
adulte handicapé soit des conjugués le
chemin que le futur président des
républicains devra prendre demain il est
aussi celui-ci celui de reparler du
handicap celui de reparler
celui de reparler de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes et aux
enfants qu'avons-nous fait
qu'avons-nous fait de ces combats
magnifiques qu'avons-nous fait de la
protection de ce que nous avons de plus
cher nos enfants dans un pays comme le
nôtre oui lorsque la semaine prochaine
nous reporterons avec mes collègues à
l'Assemblée nationale une nouvelle
proposition de loi pour mieux protéger
les femmes et les enfants comme nous
l'avons fait il y a quelques années nous
serons à la hauteur de ce que les
Français attendent de nous et de ce que
sont les grandes valeurs de la droite
républicaine le gaullisme auquel nous
croyons tous ce n'est pas celui qui se
tient loin des Français c'est celui qui
se tient tout près des Français c'est
celui qui veille dans toutes les
réformes qu'il porte à être juste
oui j'assume j'assume de vous dire que
la droite fait fausse route lorsqu'elle
pense que la seule réforme des retraites
possibles et celle de l'allogement de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite oui
je pense que la droite fait fausse route
lorsqu'elle pense que la seule réforme
sérieuse c'est celle qui consiste à
punir davantage les Français qui déjà
travaillent très dur oui je pense que la
droite fait fausse route lorsqu'elle
oublie de dire qu'aujourd'hui dans notre
pays un Français sur dix aborde l'âge de
la retraite en étant sous la pension
d'une invalidité parce qu'il a tellement
travaillé toute sa vie qu'il ne pourra
pas continuer à travailler jusqu'à 65 ou
67 ans oui je pense que la droite fait
fausse route lorsqu'elle oublie de dire
qu'il y a une autre hypocrisie dans
cette réforme des retraites c'est quand
on voulant taper sur ceux qui
travaillent déjà très dur nous allez en
chercher à financer toutes les autres
dépenses sociales dans lesquelles nous
n'avons pas le courage de faire le
ménage alors commençons par le début
commençons par faire le ménage dans le
milliard d'euros que nous coûte chaque
année l'aide médicale d'État commençons
à faire le ménage
dans les 20 milliards d'euros que nous
coûte chaque année les agences de l'État
qui bureaucratisent notre pays et
l'empêche d'avancer faisons le ménage
dans les derniers régimes spéciaux qui
sont déficitaires et qui coûte à
l'ensemble du contribuable faisant en
sorte que les 500 000 emplois vacants
que nous avons dans notre pays et qui ne
trouve pas preneur demain soit des
emplois pourvu et le jour où nous aurons
fait tous ces efforts nous aurons
récupéré suffisamment de milliards
d'euros pour aller demander à ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler dur très tôt
de continuer à le faire davantage la
vraie bonne réforme des retraites c'est
pas celle qui fait du report de l'âge
légal un totem d'autorité politique je
ne crois pas que la droite soit de même
plus crédible parce qu'elle serait plus
dur avec les Français je crois que la
droite de main elle sera plus crédible
si elle est plus juste avec les Français
oui la bonne réforme des retraites
c'est celle qui dit que celui qui a
commencé à travailler tôt fini tôt et
que celui qui a commencé à travailler
plus tard termine plus tard ce n'est pas
plus compliqué que cela d'être juste et
respectueux de ceux qui toute leur vie
on consacré la tâche au travail et à
l'effort oui
[Applaudissements]
le futur président des républicains mes
chers amis ils devront reparler de tous
ces sujets il ne doit ne devra en
oublier aucun il devra être capable de
faire en sorte que tous ces Français qui
ne nous regardent plus qui ne nous
écoutent plus ce disque de main c'est la
droite qui pourra changer leur vie mais
le futur président des républicains ce
n'est pas que celui qui va demain nous
représenter c'est aussi celui qui va
devoir remettre en ordre de bataille
notre propre famille politique fut une
époque certains l'ont connu je ne l'ai
pas connu où le président du parti était
celui qui de temps en temps regardait si
la machine fonctionnait bien il avait à
l'époque des supers secrétaires généraux
qui étaient capables de faire beaucoup
il y a eu des femmes et les hommes très
engagés à la tête du parti ils ont été
des grands présidents de parties ils
l'ont été lorsqu'ils se sont occupés de
la machinerie de quoi avons-nous besoin
de main avons-nous besoin je le redis de
quelqu'un qui rajoutera un galon sur le
revers de la veste non nous avons besoin
de quelqu'un qui tous les jours sera à
la tâche la vérité c'est que nous avons
besoin d'un mécanicien pour que notre
famille politique puisse se rénover
demain dans les idées
mais aussi dans le fonctionnement j'ai
pris l'engagement dès le mois de janvier
de revenir dans chaque fédération
d'engager à nouveau un grand tour de
France parce que oui nous aurons besoin
de faire en sorte que la vie militante
retrouve sa place dans chacun de nos
départements nous aurons besoin de faire
en sorte que la parole vous soit
redonnée qu'elle le soit sur des sujets
importants oui je souhaite demain que le
président de la commission nationale
d'investiture soit élue directement par
les adhérents je souhaite quand vous
interroge à chaque fois que nous aurons
besoin de trancher une décision
importante mais je souhaite aussi que le
futur président des républicains soit
celui qui tranche rapidement la question
de la désignation de notre candidat à
l'élection présidentielle j'aurais
sûrement l'occasion d'y revenir mais
voyez-vous je ne crois pas que reprendre
les mêmes systèmes qui nous font échouer
depuis quelques années soit une bonne
solution moi la primaire les bidules et
les machins qui ressemblent de près ou
de loin à la primaire j'en ai soupé
je n'en veux plus
ni de près ni de loin
et je vais garder un souvenir absolument
précis et absolument intacte de ce que
nous avons vécu lors de la dernière
primaire je n'ai pas oublié que derrière
la façade du rassemblement il y avait
tant et tant de division qui nous ont
poursuivi jusqu'au dernier jour de
l'élection présidentielle oui j'aurai
l'occasion d'y revenir mais je ne crois
pas je ne crois pas que en revenir à la
méthode qui fut celle du RPR soit une
méthode stalinienne lorsque fut un temps
nous en venions à désigner en bureau
politique notre candidat que nous le
faisions valider par le vote des
adhérents nous nous emportions pas si
mal et à cette époque là il n'y avait
pas un seul stalinien dans notre famille
politique il n'y avait que des
gaullistes
parce que cette méthode là elle n'est
pas soviétique cette méthode là elle
égoïste et comme nous sommes gaullistes
nous allons en revenir à la méthode des
gaullistes
celui qui demeure présidera notre
famille politique aura cette double
responsabilité nous représenter donner
envie aux Français faire en sorte que
nous soyons réellement ceux qui
apporteront des solutions au lourdes
difficultés nos concitoyens faire en
sorte que nous n'oublions aucun sujet
que nous les respections tous que nous
soyons sur le terrain en permanence ne
nous trompons pas d'élection n'imaginez
pas que nous soyons là en train de
préparer le futur candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2027 nous avons besoin
pour rebâtir cette famille si fatiguée
de quelqu'un qui tous les jours se
consacrera à la tâche
nous sommes dans une famille politique
où les talents ne manquent pas où nous
aurons besoin demain de tous nous
reparler d'en revenir à l'essentiel les
raisons de notre engagement politique
l'amour profond des Français autant que
de la France nous aurons besoin de mains
d'un président des républicains qui
n'attissent pas les guerres qui
n'attissent pas les haines et je pense
qu'il est temps pour faire en sorte que
tout le monde puisse se parler d'avoir
un président des républicains qui n'a
pas eu des années durant de conflit avec
les uns et avec les autres peut-être
peut-être que pour tourner les pages le
mieux placé est celui dont la main est
un peu neuve je ne suis pas sûr que ça
dure mais à ce moment-là notre vie
politique c'est sûrement un peu
important
n'oublions pas de nouveau nom n'oublions
pas ces 15 années durant lesquelles nous
sommes allés des chèques en échec ma
responsabilité demain de président des
républicains elle sera de reparler avec
mes amis de leur dire qu'ils ont un
talent dans nous ne pourrons pas nous
passer de dire à Eric que je lui
souhaite de toutes mes forces que demain
il puisse partir à la conquête de la
mairie de Nice qui nous débarrasse de
Christian Estrosi et qu'il devienne un
grand maire de Nice
oui je serai celui qui dira Bruno
retaillod que nous avons besoin de lui
au Sénat que le Sénat a besoin d'avoir
un président de groupe totalement
consacré concentré sur cette tâche
absolument essentielle
oui
Eric sera un grand maire de Nice Bruno
sera un grand acteur du Sénat et pour ma
part je me consacrerai à la présidence
du parti
enfin
[Applaudissements]
la terre dont je viens est une terre de
rugby cette terre là elle a trois
caractéristiques d'abord de dire les
choses aussi librement qu'elle les pense
il me semble qu'il y a bien longtemps
que nous nous parlons plus franchement
dans notre famille politique et je crois
que celles et ceux en notre saint que
nous avons tant aimé par le passé était
en réalité des femmes et les hommes qui
avaient la liberté de parler franchement
oui je ne souhaite pas que l'on s'ennuie
dans notre famille politique je souhaite
pour que les Français nous regardent à
nouveau que l'on parle toujours avec
franchise que l'on soit le plus sincère
possible cette terre de rugby elle m'a
appris cette franchise et cette
sincérité elle m'a appris le travail
d'équipe elle m'a appris que le talent
d'une équipe c'était de mettre toujours
les bonnes personnes aux bons endroits
de ne pas chercher en permanence à faire
en sorte que tout le monde soit toujours
au même poste dans les mêmes situations
cette terre de rugby
elle m'a aussi appris une chose
essentielle à faire Pâques toujours
faire Pâques si nous voulons demain
relever les défis immenses que nous
avons il nous faudra faire bloc je
voudrais mes chers amis pour terminer
que vous vous posiez une toute dernière
question et je sais que cette question
peut vous paraître un peu superficielle
mais il me semble qu'elle est un peu
essentielle tous les autres partis
politiques sont en train de changer sans
aucune exception c'est vrai en France
mais c'est aussi vrai partout en Europe
oui nous sommes à un moment politique
qui est un moment de basculement partout
en Europe et dans notre propre pays
observez à quel point la relève se lève
à l'extrême gauche observez à quel point
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a tout fait pour
organiser la relève politique
observez à quel point dans notre propre
famille politique nous devons nous poser
la question aujourd'hui observer à quel
point en macronie la relève relève aussi
observer ce qui se passe au
rassemblement national alors posons-nous
une question simple si demain nous
voulons que les Français nous écoutent
et nous regardent à nouveau il va
falloir que celles et ceux qui nous
représentent soit aussi à la hauteur de
la relève qui existe partout dans les
autres parties politiques cette
proposition-là n'est pas superficielle
elle est probablement aussi essentielle
que tout ce que j'ai eu à vous dire
jusqu'ici merci pour votre écoute
merci merci Aurélien
et on accueille avec grand plaisir le
président du Sénat monsieur Gérard
Larcher
que j'invite à prendre place
[Applaudissements]
bien alors Aurélien on va passer à
présent aux questions la première est
celle de Robin du Lot-et-Garonne il est
conseillé national comment
souhaitez-vous valoriser l'engagement
militant au sein de notre partie alors
tu as
un quart d'heure un quart d'heure et tu
as cinq questions
la question notre vie militante n'est
pas un détail et peut-être est-ce
l'occasion de vous redire ce que j'ai
dit le futur président des républicains
ce sera le premier des militants
j'insiste sur ce point lorsque je vous
dis qu'il ne faut pas se tromper
d'élection c'est précisément cela que je
veux dire le futur président notre
famille politique c'est celui qui va
devoir s'occuper avec autant
d'importance de cette question du
militantisme que de tous les autres
sujets alors oui je souhaite que nous
vous redonnions la parole c'est ce que
j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure et je pense
d'ailleurs que des trois candidats nous
sommes absolument d'accord sur ce
point-là je souhaite que dans chaque
fédération en reconquête qui sont
aujourd'hui bien bien plus importantes
que les fédérations déjà acquises nous
ayons des moyens financiers
supplémentaires parce qu'on ne pourra
pas faire la reconquête partout c'est
nécessaire s'il n'y a pas des femmes et
les hommes qui ont les moyens d'amener
j'ai dit que dès le mois de janvier
j'engagerai à nouveau un tour de France
de toutes les fédérations pour revenir
vous voir et c'est la mission précise du
futur président des républicains de
revenir à vos côtés pour faire en sorte
que dans chaque fédération la vie
militante s'organise mais il nous faut
aller un peu plus loin
observez ce qui se passe dans d'autres
partis politiques et ce qui peut nous
manquer parfois chez nous les grandes
partis politiques aujourd'hui ont
quasiment tous leur école de formation
je parle bien d'une grande école de
formation une école de formation qui est
capable de s'adresser non seulement à
nos militants à nos futurs candidats
mais aussi à tous les Français cette
école de formation c'est celle qui va
former des futurs candidats à la
bataille électorale celle que j'aurais
aimé avoir lorsque dans le lodge je suis
parti à la conquête de cette
circonscription réputée imprenable mais
cette école là elle va devoir aussi
permettre à nos idées d'infuser dans le
pays de faire en sorte que celles et
ceux qui
durant quelques semaines quelques mois
participer à notre aventure collective
puisse le faire l'extrême droite est en
train de le faire l'extrême gauche est
en train de le faire nous devons aussi
le faire je confierai dès le lendemain
de l'élection cette mission de création
d'une grande école de formation à nos
idées à nos valeurs à quatre personnes
quatre personnes
issues du terrain et c'est la dernière
chose que je veux vous dire nous avons
besoin de faire en sorte que notre
famille politique laisse plus de place à
celles et ceux qui sont engagés sur le
terrain nous devons avoir au sein de
notre bureau politique des représentants
des adhérents ce n'est pas un drame au
contraire ce sera une chance faire en
sorte qu'à chaque investiture les
fédérations est un avis pas consultatif
à donner mais un avis puissant fort qui
puisse parfois nous empêcher à un niveau
plus national de prendre des décisions
qui se révèlent ensuite être des erreurs
oui le futur président des républicains
ce sera aussi ce mécanicien et lorsque
nous aurons à voté les trois et quatre
décembre nous aurons autant à voter pour
un représentant que pour celui qui va
devoir remettre en ordre de bataille
notre machine militante
merci une question de Jeanne
de Loire-Atlantique si vos combats
sociaux sont louables pensez-vous
réellement qu'il puisse convaincre une
majorité des lecteurs de droite
c'est une bonne question que je me suis
longtemps posé moi-même
j'ai entendu souvent que ces sujets
dissociaux étaient des sujets de niche
alors posons-nous deux questions d'abord
demandons-nous si les Français
s'intéressent à nous lorsqu'on leur dit
que nous sommes des libéraux a tendance
conservatrices légèrement étatique et
parfois des centralisateurs avez-vous
vraiment le sentiment que de cette
manière là on réussit à convaincre nos
concitoyens lorsque dans le Lot je suis
réélu député avec plus de 64% des voix
dans une terre électoralement très
difficile croyez-vous que je le suis en
brandissant des concepts non je le suis
en parlant à chaque Français comme
beaucoup d'entre nous le font de ceux
qui au quotidien les blesses de ce qui
les préoccupent oui par les écologies du
défi climatique ce n'est pas être à la
marge des Français c'est être au coeur
des Français oui parler des salaires ce
n'est pas être à la marge des Français
c'est être au cœur des Français parler
du handicap de l'enfance de l'éducation
ce n'est pas se placer à côté les
Français c'est revenir directement vers
les Français je vous rappelle tout à
l'heure que moins de 2% des jeunes ont
voté pour nous que moins de 3% des
ouvriers ont voté pour nous parce que
nous ne leur parlons plus parce que nous
ne parlons plus de ceux qui fait
aujourd'hui leur sentiment réel de
dépossession il faut autant parler
d'immigration que parler de ces
questions de cohésion sociale si nous
n'en parlons pas nous décrochons des
Français et depuis quelques années c'est
précisément ce qui est en train de se
passer je voudrais que vous vous livriez
à une réflexion
observer ce que le rassemblement
national est en train de faire
n'avez-vous pas le sentiment que depuis
quelques années ils investissent tous
les sujets qui font le quotidien des
Français n'allez pas le sentiment qu'ils
ont abandonné les grands concepts et
qu'au fond l'idéologie politique qu'il
porte il la démontre par les solutions
concrètes qui sont les leurs au service
des Français n'avez-vous pas le
sentiment que nous avons parfois du mal
à avoir des idées nouvelles à faire
preuve d'imagination parfois aller sur
des sentiers qui sont des sentiers que
nous n'avons pas exploré qu'est-ce que
nous avons à dire aujourd'hui sur le
temps de travail oui nous devons dire
qu'il faut supprimer les 35 heures ça
fait 15 ans que nous le répétons une
fois que nous avons dit que nous voulons
défiscaliser les heures supplémentaires
ça fait 15 ans que nous le répétons
qu'avons-nous de nouveau à dire sur la
semaine de 38 heures réalisées en quatre
jours pour laquelle aujourd'hui les plus
grandes entreprises sont en train de
s'organiser oui nous avons besoin de se
poser cette question là parce que c'est
celle qui concerne notamment la nouvelle
génération des travailleurs beaucoup
d'autres partis font des efforts
d'imagination nous avons besoin de
redevenir la droite du concret et puis
peut-être de cesser de parler seulement
de la droite moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que nous parlions de la France que
nous parlions des Français y compris de
ces 50% de Français qui ne se sentent
pas plus de droite que de gauche
la ligne que nous devons nous fixer
c'est celle de ne jamais transiger de
n'être l'île arrière boutique du
macronisme tu as raison Bruno ni
l'arrière boutique du le pénis
nous sommes la droite républicaine et
nous n'avons à transiger avec personne
les seuls à qui nous devons parler ce
sont les Françaises et les Français et
pour retrouver le chemin des Françaises
et des Français il nous faut leur parler
de ce qui les concernent au quotidien
c'est ce chemin de reconstruction que je
merci
une question de Aziz du Val-de-Marne
délégué de sa fédération vous proposez
de désigner le candidat à la
présidentielle en bureau politique par
100 élus n'est-ce pas anti-démocratique
le choix du bureau politique sera-t-il
tout de même validé en congrès par les
militants comme Chirac ou RPR
je vous ai dit que j'étais farouchement
opposé à la primaire et j'aimerais que
sur ce sujet qu'on ne joue pas sur les
mots qu'il la primaire soit ouvert se
mit ouverte semi fermé tout ça mais
parfaitement égal ce à quoi je suis
opposé c'est le système de compétition
tel que nous l'avons déjà connu et s'il
est vrai que dans nos statuts nous avons
supprimé la primaire ouverte nous avons
maintenu ce que vous avez vécu comme moi
c'est-à-dire le dernier système de
départage je ne veux ni de l'un ni de
l'autre et je l'assume totalement
inutile de vous redire ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure cette méthode là n'est
pas soviétique cette méthode là égoïste
et puisque nous sommes gaullistes nous
devrions nous en souvenir nous devrions
nous rappeler que à chaque fois qu'on
organise des compétitions internes on
nourrit les divisions on nourrit les
divisions devant les Français et on en
sort pas plus fort alors voilà ce que je
propose je propose que dès la semaine
qui suivra l'élection nous soumettons à
votre vote la suppression définitive de
tout système de départage je proposerai
demain que ce soit le Bureau politique
qui sera représentatif et Derrick
Chiotti et de Bruno Retailleau et que ce
bureau politique de sang représentant de
nos idées puissent se mettre d'accord
sur un nom pour une raison simple c'est
que la vérité c'est que nous ne sommes
pas capables de mettre d'accord sans
personne derrière un nom alors nous ne
serons jamais capables de mettre
d'accord quelques millions de français
derrière notre candidat
il y a
il y a derrière la primaire une forme de
l'acheter c'est l'acheter qui consiste à
dire que jusqu'au bout en met la
poussière sur le tapis sur le tapis
qu'au fond parce qu'on n'est pas capable
entre nous de trouver notre propre
leader on s'en remet à des cartes plus
ou moins vrai à des adhérents plus ou
moins récents qui au final vont désigner
celui ou celle qui sera notre futur
candidat à la présidentielle j'assume
totalement de vous dire qu'il faut
rompre avec cela mais je vais ajouter un
détail un détail qui n'en est pas un
c'est que si le Bureau politique devra
se mettre d'accord sur un nom que nous
devrons nous parler franchement cesser
nos chamailleries il faudra évidemment
que ce nom soit validé par l'ensemble
des adhérents et c'est ce que je propose
un nom porté par le Bureau politique
soumis au vote des adhérents s'il y a
une majorité ce sera notre candidat à la
présidentielle s'il n'y en a pas il
faudra reproposer à notre nom
j'ajoute un dernier point
qui peut vous paraître être un petit
détail supplémentaire mais qu'il a aussi
est très important ce point là c'est
celui du calendrier je considère que
c'est une folie de vouloir désigner
l'année prochaine notre candidat à
l'élection présidentielle je considère
que c'est beaucoup trop tôt
et j'ai le souvenir comme vous qui ne
m'a pas quitté des épisodes Fillon des
épisodes Pécresse j'ai vu à quel point
il a suffi de quelques heures de
quelques jours pour que nos candidats se
fassent attirer tous les feux nucléaires
des uns et des autres et je ne pense pas
que ce soit un service que l'on rentre
dans notre candidat de vouloir l'exposer
à toutes les attaques et à toutes les
critiques quatre ans avant l'élection
présidentielle je pense que le rôle du
futur président des républicains n'est
pas de chauffer la place de l'un ou de
l'autre le futur président des
républicains il aura pour rôle de
protéger notre futur candidat à la
présidentielle de le laisser tracer son
chemin directement devant les Français
et de le désigner deux ans avant
l'élection présidentielle c'est le plan
de bataille que je vous proposerai
lorsqu'on veut
lorsque l'on veut sincèrement soutenir
notre futur candidat à la présidentielle
on ne le met pas dans un piège dès
l'année prochaine on ne l'expose pas en
le préserve et puis je veux vous dire
une dernière chose
nous sommes aujourd'hui un parti qui
croit encore mais qui a beaucoup
souffert le futur candidat à la
présidence des républicains j'ai cru le
comprendre plus ou moins clairement des
uns et des autres il ne sera pas le
futur candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2027 il faut que nous
le disions il faut que nous vous le
disions clairement parce que nous avons
le devoir de vous dire que derrière
cette élection ne se cache pas une autre
élection oui nous sommes à un moment
singulier notre vie politique ou celui
qui va devoir réorganiser la machine
politique ne sera pas celui qui sera
candidat en 2027 est-ce que c'est un
problème non je ne le crois pas je pense
que aujourd'hui cela peut être une
chance nous serons plus fort demain si
nous nous organisons en équipe si nous
mobilisons tous les talents pour que
notre futur candidat à la présidentielle
soit celui qui nous amène à la victoire
bien Aurélia il te reste 6 minutes pour
les deux dernières questions
Jean-Claude Delaude qui te demande
pourquoi souhaitez-vous instaurer des
uniformes à l'école à l'école pardon
l'autre question d'accord et la seconde
question comment faire de Julien du Nord
comment faire pour que LR soit crédible
médiatiquement face au RN et à et les
filles je vais tâcher de répondre aux
deux questions
la première est importante la seconde
est au temps
nous avons j'ai déjà oublié la première
d'ailleurs
l'uniforme
elle est essentielle j'essayais de
gagner du temps oui je l'ai pas réussi
la question de l'uniforme nous l'avons
partagé d'ailleurs les trois candidats
certains nous diront que c'est une idée
probablement ringarde à l'école au
collège et au lycée moi je ne le crois
pas j'ai été maire durant quelques
années et dans l'école de mon village
j'ai vu à la fois toutes les intrusions
extérieures souvent religieuses
aujourd'hui l'explosion considérable des
gestes qui sont ceux de l'islamisation
de notre pays et l'école est un lieu
trop sacré pour en effet commencer à
imprégner les esprits de ses tenues
vestimentaires qui n'y ont pas leur
place mais j'ai vu aussi à quel point
dans l'école de la République désormais
au premier coup d'oeil on pouvait
repérer l'enfant venu d'un milieu
favoriser et celui venu d'un milieu
défavorisé je suis un pur produit de
l'école républicaine je n'y suis pas
resté longtemps mais suffisamment pour
apprendre à aimer mon pays et apprendre
des valeurs qui m'ont profondément
structuré j'ai tellement aimé l'école de
la République que le premier candidat
que j'ai battu aux élections c'était mon
ancienne instituteur
autant vous dire que je peux dire et
assumer que je suis un pur produit de
l'école républicaine je pense qu'il nous
faut dans nos écoles et nos collèges et
nos lycées assumer que tout le monde
porte la même tenue oh ce n'est pas le
retour de la blouse de la Troisième
République c'est simplement le retour
d'une tenue unique pour chacun mais je
pense qu'il nous faut aller plus loin et
je le dis sereinement aller plus loin en
nous disant qu'à l'université on ne peut
pas ne pas régler la question de la
tenue vestimentaire je n'ai jamais
vraiment eu l'idée d'imposer à chaque
étudiant une tenue vestimentaire unique
et si certains ont pu le comprendre
c'est que je me suis mal exprimé je ne
suis pas à ce niveau de ringardise là
j'ai pris des étapes supplémentaires et
complémentaires ce que je veux dire
simplement c'est qu'il nous faut aussi
ne pas négliger la nécessité de réarmer
l'université dire demain à tous les
prévisions en université qu'ils seront
protégés que la loi dira que le voile et
toutes les tenues religieuses sont
strictement interdites dans les facultés
et les universités parce qu'elles n'y
ont pas leur place dans un lieu
d'émancip et l'apprentissage du savoir
oui le vêtement nous le savons
aujourd'hui n'est plus un détail le
vêtement est devenu aussi un outil de
revendications politiques et religieuse
communautariste nous avons donc besoin
de réarmer la République et c'est un nom
de famille politique de le faire la
dernière question elle était de savoir
comment nous devions là aussi nous
réarmer dans un contexte médiatique qui
ne nous laisse pas beaucoup de place
observer depuis quelques semaines ce qui
peut se passer dans le débat médiatique
les sujets qui intéressent le plus non
seulement les médias mais aussi les
Français sont les sujets du concret nous
l'avons vu depuis quelques heures encore
ce sont les sujets qui demain changeront
vraiment la vie des Français alors si
nous voulons de redevenir crédible il
nous faudra changer la vie de nos
concitoyens profondément c'est
d'ailleurs la raison première pour
laquelle nous nous sommes engageons
politiques si nous oublions dans toutes
nos propositions les Français il n'y a
aucune raison de nous être engagés dans
la vie politique c'est le premier chemin
pour reparler à nos concitoyens je n'ai
jamais entendu autant de français parler
de ce que nous avons pu faire que
lorsque nous avons y compris à
l'Assemblée nationale mener les combats
sociaux que j'évoquais tout à l'heure au
fond pas les combats sociaux des combats
populaires les combats qui reparlent au
peuple puis la deuxième question c'est
celle de notre représentation
nous sommes un grand parti politique ce
grand parti politique il a besoin d'être
représenté d'être incarné je ne vous
parle pas l'élection présidentielle je
vous parle bien de notre parti politique
et c'est vrai que lorsque au mois de
janvier les grands débats seront
organisés entre tous les nouveaux
présidents des partis politiques il
faudra se demander qui nous voulons
envoyer face à Mathilde panneau Aurore
berger Gabriel Attal ou Jordan Bardella
oui il faudra nous demander qui pour
reparler à tous nos concitoyens pour ne
pas sortir des radars nous avons besoin
d'envoyer pour nous représenter je vais
vous dire une dernière chose et ce sera
ma conclusion
les propos que je tiens là ne sont des
propos qui sont en rencontre de
personnes j'ai vu depuis plusieurs mois
depuis plusieurs années ce que pouvait
être dans notre propre famille politique
au-delà de nos différences ce goût du
compagnonnage absolument essentiel ce
goût de faire les choses ensemble ce
goût de ne pas se séparer en permanence
de se dire que nous avons l'essentiel au
cœur c'est-à-dire la France il y a
quelques jours nous étions à Colombey
les deux églises à midi nous avons
partagé un déjeuner et je suis allé
saluer des militants dans un autre
restaurant de Colombé ce jour-là le
patron du restaurant est venu me voir à
table il m'a dit Monsieur le Député
venait avec moi je veux vous montrer
quelque chose ce ballon de cuisine dans
la cuisine il avait punaise au mur
au-dessus du fourneau une petite photo
en noir et blanc sur cette photo il a
pointé le doigt il m'a dit Monsieur le
Député là c'était moi cette photo
c'était la photo des 11 qui ont porté le
cercueil de général de Gaulle
il me regarde et il me dit Monsieur le
Député les 11 qui étaient là ils n'avait
pas 20 ans lorsque général de Gaulle est
parti il n'avait pas souhaité que ce
soit les grands généraux qui portent son
cercueil il avait souhaité que ce soit
la jeunesse de colombes qui le fasse oui
cette photo là c'était la photo de la
relève c'était la photo des uns qui
transmettent aux autres c'était la photo
qui disait tout du fait que nos valeurs
sont si grandes qu'elles ne peuvent pas
mourir voilà ce dont il s'agit pour
l'avenir organiser les uns avec les
autres la relève politique pour que
vivent nos valeurs vivent la République
et vive la france merci